cleanin you've written about FIFA in the
past I need to give a sense of the scale
of this to an American audience is it
fair to say that if you care about this
game today is Christmas well for soccer
this is a huge event because on friday
fifa was supposed to elect will probably
rillette this president as that Blatter
who was running world soccer for quite a
long time and who presided over those
votes to grant the world cups to Russia
and Qatar but now he's probably not
going to get reelected after the arrests
so this is a huge disruptive event for
global soccer yeah and of course the the
spokesman for FIFA this morning
confirming in a press conference that
that those devotes will in fact take
place on Friday let me ask you wrote
last year and I'm quoting from the title
of your article soccer needs to kick out
its dictator explain why set bladder in
your words as a dictator was a plotter
has been at with FIFA since 1975 he
really knows the ropes in that
organization he has really mastered the
the political art of running it and of
combining satisfying all the different
interests that you know converge to make
fifa and to run world soccer he really
is the sort of the accomplished
functionary there's nobody else in
inside fee for who could stand up to him
so and help me understand this been
around too long he's been around too
long he's been president since 1998 and
their you know their allegations of
vote-rigging the go back even to that
election help me understand the
international aspect of what's going on
which is that you know the 2018 and 2022
World Cups were awarded together 2018
went to Russia Vladimir Putin had a very
personal hand in in lobbying
that world cup what does this mean to
him what does that world cup mean to
Vladimir Putin well it means less to him
than it did in 2010 when Russia actually
won that bid because back then he cared
much more what the world thinks about
him so winning the the big for the world
cup was probably as important to him as
winning the bid for the Sochi Olympics
that took place last year the Winter
Olympics and it was a major chance for
him to show off his achievements which
have sort of bailed sense with the oil
price going down and invasion of Ukraine
but it's still it's still very important
for Russia to keep the 2018 world cup
and it probably will because the you
know the bigger problem okay is with the
youth with the Qatar world cup the 2022
World Cup